a walking nightmare and I'm a Shetty
wielding killer clashed 20 years ago in
Freddy vs Jason and fans have been
begging for a sequel ever since here's
why it hasn't happened yet A Nightmare
on Elm Street and Friday the 13th
franchises were both popular profitable
Series in the 80s and 90s Freddie's last
film was almost a decade earlier and the
previous Jason flick had been a flop so
when Freddy vs Jason landed in 2003
combining them into a crossover film it
re-energize both characters and wound up
pulling in the highest box office grows
for both franchises with an estimated
116 million dollar Haul on a 30 million
dollar budget it was a huge money maker
and you'd think that it would have led
to a second crossover unfortunately
attempts to get a Freddy vs Jason sequel
have been stalled for years it wasn't
helped by the fact that both franchises
opted to reboot their respective series
with a new Friday the 13th arriving in
2009 and a remake of Nightmare on Elm
Street a year later neither were
successful enough to Warrant follow-ups
at the same time the movie Rise to Jason
and the Friday the 13 series are soon
caused in a complicated legal web that
has never been cleared up attempts to
make a sequel to Freddie vs Jason went
further than just pairing up the two
villains for a second bout however
looking for a fresh spin the studio
tried adding a third character and it
seems that they settled on one in
particular Ash Williams from Evil Dead
played by Bruce Campbell the chainsaw
wielding Warrior would have matched it
well against the machete and Claws of
Jason and Freddie the idea actually
stems from an Easter egg and Jason Goes
to Hell where a copy of the Necronomicon
from Evil Dead is implied to be
responsible for Jason's power according
to a Sci-Fi interview with the film's
director Adam Marcus he was quote
setting up a mythology that Jason's mom
wanted her son back so badly that she
reads the Necronomicon and brings about
the resurrection of a sun as a result
the Notions across all three franchises
together seemed like a natural fit
unfortunately getting the rights to both
Freddy and Jason was hard on Earth but
wrangling Evil Dead on top of it proved
nearly impossible Bruce gamble meanwhile
wasn't all that excited about the
concept and eventually he walked away
way he said on Reddit I'm not real
interested in crossovers one of the main
reasons why Ash vs Jason vs Freddy did
not come to pass is because we couldn't
control any other character other than
Ash that felt like a creatively bankrupt
way to go guys behind everything wow
there's an overstatement say what as the
rumors of a three-way battle with ashina
sequel against steam the film's director
Ronnie you addressed the gossip in 2004
speaking to creature Corner about the
possibility of merging the three
franchises he said that's something that
the studio came up with they asked me
and all the fans wanted me to do it as
well so I said yes show me the script I
would definitely do it they're still
working on the script I haven't seen
anything sadly use jab at the long
development time was frighteningly
prescient and nothing has yet to come of
it some 20 years later and he's not the
only one who's been frustrated by the
lack of movement the original film's
writers Damien Shannon and Mark Swift
are Still Holding Out for a sequel to
come to fruition in 2020 they tweeted we
still want it to get made as for the
cast Freddy actor and star Robert
England expressed his regret that they
didn't do a sequel while chatting with
two Fab in 2020 he said I think that
remakes were rushed I know the Remake on
a Nightmare on Elm Street was premature
we should have done another Freddy vs
Jason film and then waited they should
have waited for five or ten years as
we've already discussed one of the
reasons a sequel hasn't come yet is that
both franchises have since seen Clean
Slate reboots new actors were brought in
with Jackie Earl Haley putting on the
Striped Sweater to play Freddie and
future Swamp Thing actor Derek Mears
donning the hockey mask as Jason though
the 2009 version of Friday the 13th did
okay-ish at the box office neither film
got a sequel of its own but one of the
ideas thrown around by fans is to
essentially do what both franchises did
in 2003. they want to create a crossover
mashup movie to re-energize both series
at the same time recent wild rumors and
fans desires aside there's some logic to
the notion even if it's unlikely that
would get Ash Williams a battle between
the rebooted Killers could be a winning
idea with the right script a solid
director and perhaps some Legacy actors
from both franchises returning to make a
splash in fact during a 2008
conversation with MTV Derek Mears even
said he'd love to do a Freddy vs Jason
sequel although at the time Jackie O
Haley hadn't been publicly announced for
the nightmare meme yet and bills was
saying I would love to throw down
against Robert England I've been away
from my children
hard
unlike most sequels stuck in development
hell we know a lot about what the sequel
to Freddy vs Jason would have been about
that's because in 2004 Bloody Disgusting
actually published the screen treatment
on their website for all to see it was a
version that incorporated Ash Williams
and it begins where Army of Darkness and
Freddie vs Jason left off Ash is
searching for the Necronomicon the town
of Crystal Lake has been redeveloped at
Jason's house where the book resides is
to be torn down according to the
treatment Freddy is clinging to life
inside Jason's mind and a film opens of
Lori Campbell and will Rollins returning
to Crystal Lake to make sure both
villains are truly dead after a
frightening quick kill sequence we meet
our heroes a group of teens working at a
new S Mart the store where ashworx
builds in the new Crystal Lake but when
Jason learns of the Necronomicon he
plans to use it to free Freddy from his
mind and resurrect his mother he's not
the only one who knows the book is in
Crystal Lake though and Ash has arrived
to find it too leading him into a
showdown with both Freddy and Jason with
the help of his fellow S Mart employees
ultimately Freddy versus Jason versus
Ash would have turned the two villains
into reluctant allies while sending in
Bruce Campbell's Ash to stop them both
unfortunately one of the biggest reasons
that a sequel hasn't happened to this
point is that actor Robert England the
only man to portray Freddy Krueger until
2010 is no longer interested in playing
the character I won't Don the Fedora or
strap on the collage again because uh
I'm just a little too old England
doubled down on this in 2023 telling
variety I'm too old and thick to play
Freddie now I just can't do fight scenes
for more than one take anymore I've got
a bad neck and bad back and arthritis in
my right wrist so I have to hang it up
I'll love to Cameo however the horror
actor did suggest that Kevin Bacon might
make for a good Freddy saying the way he
moves might be perfect for the part with
all that said however if the screen
treatment that had been leaked by Bloody
Disgusting had ever been made we know it
would have starred England and Bruce
Campbell as well as Monica Kina and
Jason Ritter returning as survivors Lori
and will Kina even addressed the
possibility recently while talking with
the podcast happy horror time revealing
that bocian retro options for a sequel
in their contract for the first film of
course it's also likely that Ken
kurzinger would have reprise his role as
Jason too and he may even still be up
for a return if somehow a Freddy vs
Jason follow-up could ever be made he
made this clear during an appearance at
a panel during a spookala horror
convention in 2022 saying if they asked
me to do that I'd be very happy to come
back it's been two decades since Freddy
vs Jason first at theaters but that's
what you might not know is that there is
indeed a continuation of the story just
not on film The Crossover sequel took
place in comic book form a joint
production between DC Comics imprint
Wild Storm and new jersey-based
independent publisher Dynamite
entertainment titled Freddy vs Jason vs
Ash the six issue miniseries was
published in 2007 and written by James
kahoric from a story by Jeff Katz the
writer of the planned movie following
that original treatment more or less the
story sees Freddie resurrected by Jason
to the use of the Necronomicon at the
same time Ash Williams arrives in
Crystal Lake looking for the curse book
and an epic battle ensues with Freddy
resurrecting all of Jason's previous
victims as dead eyes to ashma slay but
it's what makes his sequel so unique is
that he even received a sequel of its
own Freddy vs Jason vs Ash the nightmare
Warriors published in 2009 and once
again written by kahoric based on a
story from cats this time around the US
government tries to control Freddy and
Jason's powers only to unleash them once
again on an unsuspecting populace then
it's up to us to join forces with former
survivors of both Mad Men to bring them
down and save the world given that
Freddy vs Jason brought together two
iconic horror franchises it makes sense
that it amassed a bigger audience and
either had achieved alone even after 20
years of frustration fans are still
hoping that they'll finally get a chance
to see Freddy and Jason together again
the only thing to fear
fear what's up over on change.org a
petition to get a Freddy vs Jason sequel
collected signatures from thousands of
supporters who are hoping to get
Hollywood's attention while nothing came
of it it did show just how passionate
the movies fans are likewise over on
Reddit Freddy vs Jason vs Ash often pops
up in discussions of horror sequels fans
still want to see and it remains a hot
topic of conversation to this day even
the Press is still in love with articles
podcasts and websites continuing to
publish discussions that Ponder the
possibilities of a part 2 even decades
later there are many challenges to
overcome to make a Freddy vs Jason
sequel happen a new story in script will
have to be assembled given Bruce
Campbell's interest in a crossover and
Robert England will have to be convinced
to return or be replaced by a new Freddy
the legal rights to the Friday the 13th
series will have to be cleared up which
is no easy feat while the studio will
have to be convinced that such a
crossover 20 years later can still work
but even with all that in mind there's
definitely a way it can happen when it
comes to the legal problems Studios have
shown that when there's money to be made
in a Blockbuster be produced there's not
much they won't do to get the rights
they need to make it happen for proof
look no further than Sony's
unprecedented deal with Marvel to
incorporate Spider-Man into the MCU we
admit it's probably a long shot with
everything that's working against it but
it's what the fans clearly crave and
with Crossovers and cinematic universes
All the Rage it could stand to make big
box office books